I have a truly extraordinary turn of
events to tell you about today
the plans which according to our
president and to his lawyer Rudy
Giuliani and many other people simply
didn't exist for Trump Tower Moscow have
been found and not only do plans exist
they even include the idea of bribing
Russian President Vladimir Putin with a
penthouse apartment worth 50 million
dollars in implicitly exchange for
allowing the project to go forward as
planned and this is such an incredible
situation and such a turn of events that
it's almost cartoonish in a sense I mean
the degree to which the reality differs
from the story that we have gotten from
the president and the people surrounding
him could not be more different for
months or even longer at this point
probably a year or more since the Trump
Tower Moscow issue has been sort of
floating around we've been told that
Trump Tower Moscow was basically nothing
right it was mentioned okay but Trump
himself wasn't thinking about it he
wasn't working on it he certainly wasn't
directing anyone including his lawyer
Michael Cohen to do much to push forward
the project of Trump Tower Moscow it was
more or less a silly pipe dream would
have been nice to do if it worked out
but essentially no Trump Organization
energy beyond a couple phone calls maybe
or an email here and there were put
together and were actions that were
taken we were led to believe that it was
more of a we'll look into it but nothing
actually happened at all ever and as we
heard many times there were certainly no
physical plans for the building at all
nothing specific this project was
effectively a notion buried deep in the
mind of some small number of people in
Donald Trump's organization period one
of the people fomenting that narrative
is Donald Trump's television attorney
Rudy Giuliani
who said to The New Yorker just about 48
hours ago that quote no plans
were ever made there were no drafts
nothing in the file that's a direct
quote from Rudy Giuliani and as I
mentioned yesterday Rudy Giuliani is a
lawyer but he is really serving as
Trump's public propagandist lawyer he's
not making legal statements but will
still evaluate that statement on its
merits no plans were ever made there
were no drafts nothing in the file
except that in their second blockbuster
this week BuzzFeed news it's not
BuzzFeed it's BuzzFeed news has obtained
the plans for Trump Tower Moscow they
exist they existed they were created and
those plans and text messages and emails
even outline how radomir Putin would be
effectively bribed into going along with
the project with a penthouse worth an
estimated 50 million dollars BuzzFeed
News has obtained hundreds of pages of
documents and emails and text messages
and even architectural plans and a whole
bunch of other stuff we have a rendering
of what Trump Tower Moscow was set to
look like we had also the indication
that it would be 1,500 and well it would
be taller than 1516 feet tall which was
the height of the lock test center in
st. Petersburg comparing it to other
notable world buildings including the
Commerzbank Tower and Frankfurt and the
Eiffel Tower and the shard in London
here's a rendering of what this
particular building would have looked
like in Moscow you can see it in the
context of the Moscow skyline with the
Moscow River in the background
here's a rendering of the atrium inside
Trump Tower Moscow complete with a view
again of the Moscow River out the
windows of the building and you might be
saying well if they knew that you could
see the Moscow River out the windows did
they know where the building would go
yes they did we have a map that is part
of these documents which includes the
proposed development site for the
building again right on the MA
skyriver with an amazing beautiful view
of presidency district and it turns out
that it's not just a couple of
renderings there were already
architectural plans by September of 2015
the plans laid out how Trump Tower
Moscow would be a glass obelisk it would
be 100 stories tall with this sort of
diamond like shape at the top that if
you've been watching with us you saw in
the images we showed you already not
only were there plans the plans had also
been sent to the Russian develop their
developer that was engaged to actually
do the construction that's Andrew Roz
off he indicated he was ready to get
started on this project and there is
also as Rudy Giuliani did admit there is
this finalized letter of intent signed
by Donald Trump from about a month after
the architectural plans had been filed
and that includes that this building
would contain 250 luxury condos in the
tower 15 floors of hotel with 150 hotel
rooms there would be a spa there would
be a fitness center there would be a
commercial space as well as what is
called Class A office space in the
United States or more upscale luxury
type office space the letter of intent
even specifies that Donald Trump would
be paid 4 million bucks up front he
would then get 25% when the licensing
agreement is executed 25% when the
location is finalized and the other half
of that four million based on some other
milestones Trump would get a cut of
condo sales he would get a management
fee for 25 years he would get profit
sharing from the hotel and then after
all of that which already tells us it
wasn't just a nothing notion that Trump
wasn't at all involved in and that
nobody was taking seriously there were
architectural plans there were licensing
fees and future profit streams all laid
out there then we get to the gift to
Putin for going along with all of this
the top of the building was slated to
have a penthouse apartment the market
value would be roughly 50 million
dollars and as previously reported by
BuzzFeed news the plan was to give that
away for free to
Vladimir Putin just to have himself this
was not just an idea in a trump staffers
mind because two law enforcement
officials have confirmed that Michael
Cohen Trump's lawyer personally
discussed gifting the penthouse to
Vladimir Putin with an aide to Putin's
press secretary and it could have even
gone further than that we just aren't
sure yet this is what we call a bribe
okay Russian oligarch Felix seder who
was working with Trump on this and was a
key player in the Trump Russia probe is
on record saying quote my idea was to
give a 50 million dollar penthouse to
Putin and to charge 250 million more for
the rest of the units all the oleg arks
would line up to live in the same
building as Putin Seder was involved in
gifting the penthouse to Putin Michael
Cohen was involved in discussions about
that and aid to Putin's press secretary
was involved in that discussion and then
we get to the degree of involvement that
Donald Trump may or may not have had
Donald Trump has denied having any
interests in Russia he's denied being in
regular contact with anybody about this
project but BuzzFeed who did their
homework on this can now report that
Donald Trump received at least 10
updates about the project that they know
of specifically and of course in all of
this is the allegation that Trump
directed Michael Cohen to lie to
Congress about it on the basis of that
BuzzFeed news report from a few days ago
the cherry on top this tweet from Trump
in 2013 directed at Arras a gala Rove I
had a great weekend with you and your
family you have done a fantastic job
Trump Tower Moscow is next Amin was WOW
Ameen as I believe I Ross's son and was
involved in that
Trump Tower meeting that took place in
2016 so what's next it's going to be
what Rudy Giuliani's saying of course we
had plans it's a real estate deal you
need plans but so what making plans
isn't a crime licensing agreements
aren't crimes gifting penthouses to
presidents of foreign countries to get
deals approved that's not a crime this
is just business and then the next day
Rudy will tell us that was a
hypothetical statement that I made that
wasn't a legal statement I was
hypothetically quoting myself as Trump's
attorney but it was just hypothetical it
wasn't real and of course it would also
be wrong because there is this thing
called the Foreign Corrupt Practices Act
of 1977 it's also called FCPA
and it very specifically has anti bribe
provisions regarding using money or
things of value to influence or obtain
authorization for or promises from
foreign officials in their official
capacity so for everybody saying there's
nothing here this is merely a
businessman Trump trying to build a
tower that's not true there are a lot of
issues here it might violate the Foreign
Corrupt Practices Act it would be
indicative of the fact that Donald Trump
was not telling the truth about his
involvement here all along there are all
sorts of different crimes potentially
tied up in this the penthouse was a
thing of value offering it to Putin to
get an advantage in terms of permitting
and going forward with the project could
indeed be criminal and then lastly the
other potentially criminal element here
this project was set to receive funding
from the VTB Bank in Russia VTB Bank at
the time that these discussions were
going on was under sanctions by the
United States of America which makes the
financing of Trump Tower Moscow which we
now know did have architectural plans
it makes the fine the financing
potentially illegal as well so what will
they say will they say the BuzzFeed
report is simply wrong because every
time they do that BuzzFeed comes out
with more documents documentary evidence
about this will they say well Cohen
acted alone he's a liar and a convicted
felon does anybody believe for a moment
that Donald Trump would be not involved
in the plans to build the biggest
building in Europe including the gift of
a 50 million dollar penthouse to
Vladimir Putin when 9/11 happened Trump
went on TV and bragged as a result of
9/11 and
Twin Towers being knocked down his
building is now the tallest in lower
Manhattan does anybody believe that a
guy who does that that that's what he
thinks of when the twin towers are
knocked down by foreign terrorists does
anyone believe he wouldn't be involved
in the building of the tallest building
in Europe which was set to have his name
on it every single lie here is falling
apart let me know your thoughts i'm on
twitter at des Pakman and the show is on
twitter a David Pakman show